- This week ESPN obtained
emails and text messages
that provided more information
on a rape allegation
against Mavericks star former
Knick, Kristaps Porzingis.
The acquistion that ESPN had
was essentially a
handwritten agreement
between Porzingis
and his accuser
in which he allegedly
promised to pay $68,000
to her brother's college
fund in order to keep quiet.
He never paid that
money according to her,
and now she is suing him.
- Now, listen.
This has got to be
the best sister ever
if she's just like,
"You know what?
"I was sexually assaulted.
"Gotta think about my
brother on this one.
"Got to pay down
those student loans.
"Make it worth it."
- And the document came
out that was signed
according to her
lawyers that night.
So he played in a game
that day, that night.
He tore his ACL in that game
so it was a big
moment for his career.
She lives in his
apartment building,
and according to her,
they stayed together
until the morning,
and by the end of it, he
signed that agreement.
- Well, he said he got
drunk with his brothers.
His brothers were there.
It's like there's a
video documenting that
that they did shots of tequila.
They go back to his place.
They're getting drunk.
I think she may have
drank with them.
I might be wrong about that.
But then she says she went
up later on late that night
to get an autograph?
Was that her excuse?
And then he assaulted her.
She says they spent
the night together.
He agreed to $65 grand,
and then pulled out an agreement
like he pulls out
of so many things.
And then she went to the police.
You know, I think...
I feel bad for the
brother, you know,
who thought this
was his big chance,
and again, this
is a crazy story.
It just keeps getting crazier.
I think it's crazy
that Mark Cuban...
Like when they made the trade
from the Knicks to the Mavs,
everyone knew about it.
The NBA's known about
this for quite some time.
I don't know what to think.
There's a lot of
different stories here,
but I'll tell you this.
We here at The Rosenthal
and Jeselnik Vanity Project.
- JRVP.
Junior Vice President.
- Did I fuck it up?
- You did.
- Let's go back.
We here...
Cause I wanna make sure
this point is driven home
like we would drive
home a lover afterwards.
- That's right.
- Even though we're demanding.
We would demand
to drive them home
to make sure they're safe,
no matter how drunk we were.
- That's right.
- As a threesome.
- One of us would be fine.
- We here at The Jeselnik
and Rosenthal Vanity Project
- JRVP.
Junior Vice President.
- We believe the victims.
- Greg, what's
our next headline?
- I mean, I could just say it.
You don't have to ask me
what the next headline
is every time.
- But I wanted to know
because I feel like that
last one was a hardcore one.
Erica's Corner
was overtly sexual
in a way that, I think,
made us all uncomfortable.
I feel like whatever Stu's
doing on his honeymoon right now
ain't as sexy as what
we're doing in here.
- I mean this is a
pretty sexy story, too.
If you like the last 15
minutes of this show,
you are gonna love the news
out of Australia this week
that an Aussie appeals
court decided on Friday,
they dismissed a bullying
case against a former boss
by an ex-employee
of his who alleged
that the boss repeatedly
farted around him
and that constituted bullying
over the course of nine months.
He's suing him for $1.3 million
for farting upwards of
five to six times a day
in the man's small
windowless office.
- And he claims he did
it strictly to bully him.
Like he would walk
into the office
and let one go and then leave?
- Yeah, the supervisor's
name was Greg Short
which just feels like a
perfect name for a guy
who would go into
another guy's office.
The thing that really got me
was it was five to
six times a day.
- But they didn't work
in the same office.
The guy would come in...
- It was his boss.
Yeah, not in the same office,
but he would come in,
and there's no windows.
It's a small office,
and then he would
fart on the guy
you know, many times a day,
and he would talk about it.
It wasn't just like he would
kind of like sneak up and do it.
He would, you know,
make jokes about it,
and he's like he thought
it would be funny
if he did it like once or twice,
but he was saying
this guy did it
like five or six times
a day, every day.
- That was, that was...
So three was the breaking point.
Like once you get
past one or two,
that's too much.
I like that in Australia
bullying is illegal,
but they can't define bullying.
I had a science teacher
my freshman year
who was a crazy person
who was like pretty
normal in all aspects
but if he ever smelled anything
that smelled like
it could be a fart,
he would like close
the door of the class
and yell at all of us.
Be like, "Guys, who did it?
"Who farted right now?"
And one time he is
cleaning out an aquarium
with like a vacuum,
and the smell is horrific
because it's like fish shit
and whatever is in an aquarium.
It smells so bad,
and he stops the vacuum,
pulls all the guys
into the other room,
and goes, "Guys, who
shit themselves?"
And we're all laughing so hard.
He's getting madder and
madder that we're laughing.
We have no idea what
he's talking about.
He brings us all
back into class,
and in front of
the girls and guys,
gives us a speech about how
if anyone ever passes gas
in his classroom ever again,
they're getting kicked out
and they're going to the office,
and we're trying to hold
it together so badly,
and I have the presence
of mind to raise my hand
while he's yelling,
and the guy who sat next to me
was a friend of mine
named Justin Bayer.
Shout out to Justin.
And I raise my hand, and I say,
"Mr Leeds, while
you were talking,
"Justin farted three times."
And Mr. Leeds blows his stack,
goes, "Justin, get up
and get out of here."
And Justin on the
verge of tears is like,
"You're not going to
tell him you're joking?"
And I'm laughing too
hard to say anything,
and he got sent to
the office that day
which was one of
the funniest things.
- What do you tell
the principal?
I like farted.
- He said like he passed gas,
and then I had another friend
who got in the same trouble
where Mr. Leeds yelled
at him for farting.
He's like, "Mr. Leeds,
it's a bodily function.
"I can't help it."
And Mr. Leeds sent
him to the office,
and the principal says,
"So Mr. Leeds tells me
"that you told him you'll
fart whenever you want,
"and there's nothing
he can do to stop you."
And he was like, "No!
"Why is this guy so crazy?"
He's a biology teacher
who couldn't stand a
biological function.
- What happened to
Mr. Leeds as a child
that led to this?
Maybe he was bullied.
- I think looking back,
I think it's very
possible that Mr. Leeds
smoked marijuana
throughout the school day.
I think that was his problem.
He was a fun teacher,
but I wouldn't say he
inspired anyone to do anything
except never fart.
- Like he didn't
really teach you much,
but he taught you that.
- Mm-hmm.
- That's something.
The strangest part of
this story was though
that this all happened over
the course of 11 months
a decade ago.
Why is he only
suing the guy now?
He's been holding this in
mentally for that entire time?
And even though
this got dismissed,
he's trying to take it
to essentially the Supreme
Court in Australia.
He wants to take it to court.
- You know, sometimes,
speaking of biology,
sometimes when people fart,
it doesn't smell right away.
You know what I mean.
There's a little delay on it.
So it could've been 11 years.
You don't know how things
work down in Australia.
Toilets flush backwards.
It's a different kind of place.
- What is bullying though?
Would you consider
our actions...
Like last week, you
were very sensitive
about the way that Erica and
I don't always lift you up
as the star of the show.
We bring up
embarrassing stories.
- Why are you saying we?
Erica's never once brought
up an embarrassing story.
- You threw here.
Yeah, you threw her into
that, too, last week.
You were saying that, you
know, we don't do a good...
Fine, myself.
Does that constitute bullying?
- No, I haven't been
bullied in quite some time.
- Okay.
- Another Mr. Leeds story.
Mr. Leeds and his...
He was like, "You get extra
credit if you get a pet
"and bring it in here
and keep it in a tank."
Like you can get a fish.
People had piranhas.
People had different things,
and me and my friend, Jason
Basonge, shout out to Jason,
went to the store
and bought a snake
and brought in like a
tiny little baby snake.
It looked so cool.
We called it Brimstone Love,
and we put it in a cage,
and we're like, "Mr.
Leeds, how do we take care
"of this thing?"
And he goes, "Oh, just
put sand in there,
"like a little bit of water,
"and put like a
heat lamp over it."
The next day, the snake is dead.
It's kidneys have
exploded from dehydration
and overheating,
and I go, "Mr.
Leeds, what the hell?
"Like what the hell is this?"
And Mr. Leeds goes, "Oh,
I don't like snakes."
And we were like, "All right.
"Do we still get extra credit?
"Cool, cool."